i was like i look side enough
oh no another one good last chance for
jinko's only minus ten is he going under
anything
come on he's gonna do it moy kusanagi
playing spoiler right now four
oh my goodness wow
oh look
fluffy a lady
[Music]
[Laughter]
was scary when he approaches like that
like that
he sucks
right he's gonna have a pixel
pixel it's a big-ass pixel oh my god oh
[ __ ]
he's dead he got him done with the three
round straight stole every round two oh
my god the whiff just in his face that
one was so hard to tell so hard to tell
though
oh got him hit him with it
down two two doesn't get the break of a
wall with it back with too early python
gave him a chance one pixel oh
down forward one he's got rain in the
tunnel
he's going down oh my god
is he living
oh the little door scaling the floor
scaling thank goodness
this is the oh he got the just frame he
got the extra damage he got the throw
damage and the grounded damage
oh my god
dude it's looking up get back down here
i'm not going with you
guys
one energy
he's having his way with this wall
mixture the tackle for the wind
blocked tackle for the wind do it again
in games
again
all through the round robin fools
[Music]